le foot c'est un lieu de passion et
d'jeu c'est un sport de masse ça attire
les foues ça attire les
[Musique]
passions l'objectif premièrement c'est
de montrer que la Côte d'Ivoire est une
terre de foot et aussi une terre de
champions et que l'hospitalité dont elle
se pr
n'est pas un 20 mot mais que ça a été
traduit dans une politique d'accueil des
footballeurs de très haut niveau sur la
longue durée et puis l'autre objectif
c'est de valoriser les les Archives
nationales et puis de faire signe aux
politiques pour leur dire que s'ils
veulent créer un musée du football ou
tout simplement un musée du sport il y a
de la matière pour
réussir
[Musique]
j'ai
choisi ben Badi c'est un ancien c'est
quelqu'un que on connaissait quand on
était plus petit et lui c'est Dra et lui
c'est Yaya c'est les joueurs qui ont
marqué ma vie mon parce que c'est c'est
les deux générations que j'ai connu
vraiment je garde de des gens qui nous
ont amené au foot à aimer le
foot
c'est Côte d'Ivoire 84 le moment où la
Côte d'Ivoire organise la première canne
et le moment où la Côte d'Ivoire
commence à croire politiquement de
manière très forte au foot et vu
l'engouement que la canne suscite oufou
boagi à la fin de ce tournoi que nous
avons perdu dit maintenant je comprends
que je dois m'intéresser au foot à
partir de ce momentl il mett en place un
dispositif qui consiste à stabiliser
l'équipe nationale elle-même autour de
Gadi selli qui est le capitaine qui est
chargé euh en quelque sorte de mener ce
travail de
réforme le moment 92 c'est le moment où
on gagne c'est un peu cette salle où on
est et c'est un moment qui est qui est
décisif on a joué contre le Ghana CIT un
match nul c'est une canne qu'on a joué
pratiquement sans marquer sans prendre
but euh mais euh nos victoires se
décident toujours sous la base de
pénalty et vous verrez que Alain guamé
qu'on est en train d'embrasser ici et il
vient juste de réussir à bloquer le
dernier pénalti des des
ganéens septembre 2002 euh le pays est
pratiquement divisé en deux en ce moment
euh les politiciens comprennent qu'ils
peuvent jouer euh ou mettre en scène la
réconciliation en en envoyant des
équipes les équipes de football les
matchs de football des éléphants o il
peuvent les localiser à l'intérieur du
pays à boaké qui est la capitale de la
rébellion et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
que le stade de boaké s'appelle stade de
la paix donc toutes les qualifications
de la Côte d'Ivoire tous les matches
sont négociés là-bas et ça permet de
ressouder un pays qui en fait est
tendantiellement divisé et quand la Côte
d'Ivoire finit par se qualifier pour
cette Coupe du monde les les joueurs de
l'équipe national font cette imploration
ils demandent vraiment donnez-nous la
paix on en a besoin donc ça a été un
moment très très émouvant et c'était les
rares moments où la plupart des
Ivoiriens euh se sentaient fiers unifiés
derrière leur équipe
nationale 2015 lorsque nous gagnons
notre 2e médaille alors cette le moment
de cette deuxème médaille ça correspond
à un moment où euh le football euh les
les joueur l'essentiel des joueurs vie
et travaill à
l'étranger